you
hey youtubers is Charlie so daredevil
season 3 teaser trailers they just had a
big Wizard World panel so I'm going to
do a breakdown of all the stuff they've
been saying about season 3 so but you
did not expect the teaser trailer to be
dropping this early this is all part of
like the big comic-con netflix roll out
with punisher season 1 the big
announcement that they're working on
that they kind of slipped this and
they're like hey we're working on
daredevil season 3 if you didn't know
but i feel like we all assumed they were
going to do it the thing with the Marvel
Netflix there is just the rule of thumb
is that they will keep making it as long
as the actors keep wanting to do it so I
would expect at least another cycle or
two of the defenders team-up so what
we've had is is like each of the heroes
have had at least one of their own solo
series then they all team up then they
rinse and repeat so after defenders will
see daredevil season 3 so I'm not
expecting you to drop till 2018 but
that's just tentative the dates for
everything can change like they say the
punisher like in the punisher teaser
trailer they say it's coming 2017 it can
wind up coming a little bit after that
so like all the dates are in flux but
the thing here like you know the train
station if you guys haven't ever rid the
subway in New York this is an actual
picture of what one of the subway stops
looks like but you know just like the
Hell's Kitchen stop with the blood
hitting the 3 just to represent season 3
so it's just a nice visual teaser for
that a lot of you have asked if they're
finally going to bring bull's eye on the
TV show I think that they will I think
he'll be like the big new character but
anybody who's been in any of the Netflix
series is game to crossover like they'll
be Punisher during daredevil season 3
maybe not quite as much as there was
during season 2 but at the Wizard World
panel just to do like a quick breakdown
of what they did during that they talked
about what's going to be happening a
little bit they can't tease too much
because they're still working on scripts
so there's not a whole lot to know about
it yet they're still working on
defenders right now in the people like
the show runners from daredevil season 2
are the show runners for the defender
series so the people who are riding
daredevil season 3 are the same people
that did season 2 and doing defenders so
it'll just be like this continuous story
so whatever happens during season 3 in
terms of plot will just be like the next
logical step from what happens at the
end of defenders namely kingpin probably
getting out of prison in coming after
daredevil born-again style I'm hoping
they do a version of daredevil born
again if you guys don't know that
big Frank Miller storyline it's really
bad for Karen page they're probably
going to change some of her character
she becomes a prostitute she goes to buy
drugs and sells out daredevil secret
identity kingpin finds out and he
proceeds to make Matt Murdock's life a
living hell over three volumes in fact
the first arc of it is called living
hell
where kingpin uses the information to
throw Matt Murdock under the bus he uses
the law against Matt Murdock so all of
Daredevils bank accounts get frozen he
gets kicked out of his house he gets
thrown on the street he doesn't trust
his friends it's just a complete living
hell as the name implies the next arc is
called purgatory with him living on the
street and then the final arc like the
big resolution is called heaven so as
you would expect with the daredevil
story heavy-handed religious themes any
daredevil story is going to have a lot
of religious overtones but there's a
whole bunch of crossover and even the
new character who was actually the guy
that took the pills
during Jessica Jones season one if you
remember him kingpin releases nuke and
sets him on daredevil so this is big
nuke vs. daredevil fight but nuke is
like completely jacked up on those pills
so I don't I don't think they're going
to do an exact comic book storyline but
like daredevil season 2 was daredevil
versus Punisher like the big arc from
the comics there'll be some of that too
like they'll do a big arc from the
comics but it'll be their version so
they'll change some things namely the
Karen page character Frank Miller's
version of Karen page is just like the
worst portrayal of a female character
ever but I have to represent my lers a
couple of you have told me that you
haven't finished your double season two
you so during season two Elektra dies
and then she's being resurrected like
they imply that she's being resurrected
by the hand as the black sky possessed
by the demon that they worship so that
when she comes back she'll be like this
super evil version of Elektra super
powerful super evil that will come to
fruition
during defenders so when we get to
daredevil season 3 whatever ends up
happening I'm expecting her to still be
alive but maybe they'll redeem her maybe
she'll still be evil but Elektra is
still around even if she's not going to
be a big part of season 3 so in terms of
new characters they always introduce
like one or two big new comic book
characters I think the bullseye like
everyone's expecting it to be bull's eye
I definitely think it's going to be
bull's eye so quick recap daredevil
season 3 probably dropping
sometimes spring 2018 will probably
introduce the bullseye character as a
mercenary hired by kingpin to go after
daredevil but just to remind you guys if
you didn't know what the order is for
the Netflix series so we have Luke Cage
that's going to be dropping September
30th then we're going to see Iron Fist
in the spring of next year then we'll
see the defenders team-up then we'll see
Jessica Jones daredevil season 3 all the
other series Punisher season 1 you get
the idea so when we do get to Luke Cage
later this year
just expect them to start teasing out
iron fist because I definitely think
that iron fist is going to show up
during Luke Cage it just makes sense
that they would want to introduce them
at the end of that let me know in the
comments what do you guys want to see
during daredevil season 3 I know you
want to see some Punisher stuff everyone
wants to see bullseye but what comic
book arcs do you want them to adapt I
just feel like born-again would be an
easy slam-dunk like a version of born
again they'd have to change a couple
things like Aaron Paige is terrible
during born again but if you do want to
read the comic book story it's a great
Frank Miller story if you really like
Frank Miller's version of daredevil so
if you guys didn't see it in my last
video I started a new round of the
Marvel giveaway it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so what's going to happen is
is because Luke Cage is dropping at the
end of next month we'll probably see a
whole bunch more Luke Cage stuff in the
next couple weeks so there'll be a whole
bunch of Marvel Netflix I'll do some
more Jessica Jones season 2 because they
already started working on that too like
the showrunner for Jessica Jones is
working on season 2 right now we get
height there's so much Marvel Netflix
stuff happening Heroes for Hire Jessica
Jones daredevil Punisher and that's not
even talking about the movies like I
just did a movie video talking about all
the crazy movie stuff that's happening
and then we have all this Netflix stuff
so Marvel is just like killing it
everywhere why you guys wait for my next
video you can click here for the Thor
Ragnarok behind the scenes video and you
can click here for the punisher season 1
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight